[Music]
6 25 on your friday morning here's a
good question would this drive you crazy
will there be hov
lanes where the 95 meets the 215
northern beltway we're going
centennial bowling
so again the question hov lanes in the
centennial bowl while tony illya at the
nevada department of transportation says
there are no immediate plans to add
additional hov lanes at the centennial
however
a nearby supposedly hov only on ramp to
the south 95 getting the attention of
viewer linda who writes
about getting on to the south 95 from
elkhorn she says hey it says
hov entrance lane but i see single
occupants using it all the time
i don't want to try and get a ticket
could you solve this mystery for me
because my maps app says to go ahead and
use it to be very convenient if i could
well
linda tony says that unwrap is reserved
for vehicles with two or more people
including buses carpools van pools as
well as motorcycles and first responders
he goes on to encourage linda to take
advantage of the regional transportation
commission's free club ride program that
puts together like-minded commuters to
try to save time money and air quality
and about those single occupant drivers
who should not be using that ramp tony
says
illegal use of the hov rack by
ineligible motorists is an
enforcement issue for the nevada highway
patrol so linda
i don't know if that helps at all but we
appreciate your taking the time to write
in i will check with the nhp on their
response we'll let you know what they
have to say buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight eight news now
dot com